Alright.
Hello everyone.
One a day at Google.
My name is Eileen Naughton.
I lead people I'm ratios and we are so happy.
It's just so heartwarming to be here today of all days on international women's
Day and to be able to welcome a panel of incredible talent from the new Disney
film,
a wrinkle in time,
which opens tomorrow,
March 9th worldwide.
So we are here to celebrate a number of strong,
courageous women who are helping steer us all to a more equitable future.
Now we're about to me are extraordinary panel,
but first let me introduce it in the room with us today.
40 Young Women From Girls Inc
nonprofit organization that encourages all girls to be strong,
smart,
and bold through direct service and advocacy.
Welcome girls.
Yeah.
These girls were invited by Google's made with code program,
a movement that Google is proud to support a movement to equip women with the
skills they need to embark on any career path they choose,
including careers in science,
technology,
engineering,
and math.
And given that Madeline linguals novel of wrinkle in time is often cited as
inspiration for women who have taken careers in science.
We hope today brings similar inspiration.
Okay.
We're going to introduce the cast.
So I'd first like to welcome the wise and wonderful Oprah Winfrey.
Oh,
Bruh.
You have some fans.
Yeah.
Water.
Oh,
for his humanity and sage advice have touched us deeply.
And by us I mean humankind.
Oprah is a media icon,
an Oscar nominated actress,
producer,
philanthropist.
She's also one of my favorite things about to Oprah.
So you're the founder of the Oprah Winfrey Leadership Academy for Girls in South
Africa,
which provide
it's educational and leadership opportunities for academically gifted girls from
a disadvantaged backgrounds.
Thank you for that.
Bit Supportive Girls Inc too.
Oh,
is a fairy godmother as she plays Mrs which and a wrinkle in time.
Welcome Oprah.
Ava,
Ava duvernay
filmmaker,
producer and screen writer who directed a wrinkle in time.
And the 2014 2014 Oscar nominated
the film Selma,
which chronicles Dr. Martin Luther King's journal Juniors leadership in the
struggle for voting rights.
Eva has the rare distinction of being an academy award and Golden Globe
nominated director of both documentary and feature films.
Welcome Ava.
Next we have storm rain.
Storm is here.
Start again.
Day when she was three years old,
she's 14 right now.
So she's growing up right before her eyes.
Storm plays the lead role of make Murray in a wrinkle in time
and among other roles,
storms
appeared in the Academy Award winning film 12 years a slave.
And we have Google but burrata,
an English actress known for many roles in British TV and film including
recurring role and the doctor who TV series
and pluming and beauty and the beast.
[inaudible] more than half the rose that Google has appeared in,
were directed by
women,
which is in itself quite notable.
And then wrinkled time she plays Meg's mother.
Wonderful.
Makes mother.
So why don't we sit down ladies and start?
Uh,
I was able to see a wrinkle in time this week and it's a magical visually and
chanting movie about a young girl who travels across a time space dimension to
save her father,
a physicist from dark forces in the universe.
Now,
what really struck me in the movie,
it was how central women are to the entire storyline make.
Marie is not a damsel in distress.
She has a young woman on a mission to find her father,
and she was aided in her quest by kind boys and men and by mystical,
magical,
powerful women.
So congratulations ladies on a great achievement.
Ava.
No,
I understand that
you weren't expecting and might have been surprised to receive a call from
Disney to direct this film and you hadn't read Madeline angles a novel before,
uh,
being offered this project.
What was it about the script and the project that really appealed to you?
Thank you all for being here.
I want to say about,
um,
the women in the book,
uh,
and in our film is that,
Google and Botha.
Raul does not play just her mother.
She's an astrophysics astrophysicist.
She's doctor Kate Marie,
which is really important because we want to make sure that,
that we know that girls can participate in stem,
that's important than medicine,
education,
math,
science,
all that good stuff.
So we want to make sure we point that out.
Um,
don't ask her to do any math problems,
so you're on this page,
but,
but she does them in the movie.
Um,
but yeah,
it was really cool to get a call from Disney because sometimes in Hollywood,
Hollywood likes you to ask for permission.
Just like a lot of people in life want girls and women to ask for permission to
do things.
Um,
they want us to,
uh,
sometimes,
um,
uh,
pitch ourselves and,
and,
and sometimes to prove that you're worth doing something.
And so we find that a lot of places in life,
but now,
and then you get a beautiful experience when people welcome you in and they love
you just the way you are.
And that's what happened to me at Disney.
They called me and they said,
we love your work.
We love your voice and we want you to just come in and be who you are.
And those are the kinds of experiences you want to embrace.
Those are the kinds of people you want to align yourself with.
And that's a,
those are the kinds of people that we were able to make a wrinkle in time with
our Disney as a remarkable story.
You did not pick up a camera to direct until you were 33.
No,
that's old.
We'll all the kids.
No,
that's old.
That's very young.
Actually.
Older four,
um,
four directors.
Cause most directors start 20,
21,
uh,
in their early twenties.
So,
so to start in your,
in your thirties,
um,
it's,
it's a,
it's unusual.
So what advice would you give women and particularly young girls about following
their dreams,
their tropisms and having courage?
It's really just what you're doing now does not have to be what you always do.
Who you are right now is not who you are always going to be and just know that
there are steps to take.
There are other paths to follow to explore,
but don't feel stuck in one place.
Embrace where you are now.
Learn what you can from it,
but also stay open to the fact that there are other things that you can do.
A lot of people talk about me and my journey in terms of race and gender,
but part of my story is also age because in the industry that I'm in,
I got to start quite late and it's just proof that nothing is impossible.
Nothing is impossible,
ladies and gentlemen.
Okay.
Oprah,
the character you play,
Mrs,
which is the wisest woman in the universe.
And as Ava said in casting you,
she picked the wisest woman in Rio.
Wow.
When you see them,
when you see the movie,
it's fantastic.
Gorgol and their times.
We'll get to you in a moment.
Yay.
Hello.
Ms. Watson just came from the United Nations where she was representing women
are for International Women's Day,
so thank you Reese for being here.
We were just in the middle of talking about the remarkable character,
Mrs,
which,
uh,
that Oprah
plays and this larger than life figure who,
uh,
guides meg through the universe and it gives her courage.
Tell me what it is about this role that appeal to you.
Well,
I have to say,
well first of all,
let me just say that one of the reasons this role happened to me is because I am
a friend of Ava.
Do An,
I do not use that term lightly because over the years I have chosen my friend
carefully.
And um,
I have had,
uh,
a best friend,
Gail,
who's been my best friend since we were 21 and 22.
I actively sought another friend
because Gail is busy a lot.
And uh,
I actively sought in another friend.
So someone had shown me a DVD of Eva's work for another movie called the middle
of nowhere.
And when I,
I liked the movie and then I went and looked up,
googled her,
I googled her,
hello,
go,
go.
I go though.
And there
I saw this,
this,
the,
this essence of someone who I wanted to be my friend.
First of all,
she was a girl with glasses.
She looked like me and I thought,
Gee,
I want to be a friend.
So I actively sought to create an event so that she could come to my house.
And then so she went,
so,
so that she would be my friend.
So,
uh,
that worked.
And then I,
as a friend,
I,
I w when you have a friend that you love and you care about,
you want to do everything you can to support your friends.
That's the kind of friend you want.
You want a friend that wants for you as much as you want something,
they want it even more.
So I wanted to support my friend in doing this film.
So I said,
I'm gonna come to New Zealand,
girl,
I'm a watch you work and say,
action.
I just want to,
I just want to be there when you tell all those people action and cut.
And so she said,
oh.
And I kept saying it.
I'm coming to New Zealand girl,
I'm coming to New Zealand.
And she said,
if you're really going to do that,
would you uh,
consider reading this part?
And I said,
yeah girl,
I'll do that.
So that's how,
that's actually how it happened because I was seeking her as a friend.
I saw something in her essence that has turned out to be even more profound.
So then I read this role and it's like everything I could imagine for myself.
So I had a wonderful mother friend,
teacher,
Mentor named Maya Angelo.
Do you know who that is?
So I read her book when I was about your age and then I ended up being her,
becoming her daughter,
like,
and so she was my spiritual guide,
mentor teacher.
And I model this character Mrs,
which from Maya Angelou and from the wizard of Oz Glinda,
the good witch.
So when Glenda,
the good witch says you've always had the power,
I think that's one of the greatest teaching.
So to be able to have Maya Angelou and Glinda the good witch,
and then a bit of my own self in there.
Because in the very beginning when she,
when Mrs,
which first shows up at the beginning of the film and she says to May egg,
all you have to do is find the right frequency and have faith and who you are.
That is my true philosophy for how you live your life.
And if I had any advice to give to you all today,
that is it.
It starts at the beginning of the movie.
All you have to do is find the right frequency because everybody has their own
frequency.
That is just yours.
And when you can ride that frequency,
find the flow that is for you and have faith in that unimaginable things become
possible for you.
So that's why I love the movie for that message and for my friend
Ava.
Beautiful message.
And it's a beautiful lesson for us here today.
And I think Reese,
welcome.
You have found your fright frequency lately.
It's remarkable.
You all know Reese Witherspoon,
actress,
director,
entrepreneur,
she has her own production company.
Hello Sunshine,
which really is your frequency,
but you've also be,
become really actively involved in a number of women's advocacy organizations.
And for that we thank you.
Um,
I understand you read this book when you were a young girl and how did you feel
that Eva's film enhances the story and makes it more relevant to the world that
we're living today and experiencing today?
Well,
the book was written quite awhile ago.
I think ava did an extraordinary job.
I read this book when I was 12 and I loved it.
And I think primarily because I love science fiction and I hadn't read a lot of
books that had a girl at the center of it.
So I thought I was Meg Murray and I was going to travel through the universe and
do amazing things.
And um,
and I loved all of that.
And then I read every book in the series.
So I was just completely obsessed.
And,
um,
so when ava caused me to be in and out,
I was so excited.
I didn't know who I would play either because the is are all like billions and
billions of years old.
My son said,
we're just wants you to play at all lady.
But she of course,
at this beautiful vision of making them timeless,
you know,
and Celeste steel and intergalactic and that they had this,
um,
and they have these qualities that are,
uh,
the,
the qualities that you'd want to have three incredible women guide you through
the universe wisdom,
a sense of fun and a sense of past.
And,
um,
I just think it was beautiful the way she imagined it.
And do you have one of the most beautiful transformations from a somewhat human
form into this mystical flying creature that was one of the most exciting scenes
in the movie.
Can we talk a little bit about the special effects and the challenge in creating
a movie like that so heavily relies on technology really to,
to produce these effects?
Yeah,
no,
I,
I think,
um,
you know,
it was a beautiful team,
uh,
that,
that worked on the film and that special effects with me,
our visual effects supervisor,
rich McBride,
also great woman over at Disney who heads up special fix their Mimi,
steal another woman.
Tamra cancel a lot of women on our special effects are and our visual effects
team.
But I think the actress that was most impacted by the visual effects with storm
Reid,
because I'm storm Reid as meg Murray gets to fly.
And that's one of the reasons why I wanted to make this movie,
to see a girl fly hot planets,
uh,
save the world from the darkness and do all these amazing things.
So,
but storm actually,
you know,
put her in a harness,
hiked her up in the air and she had to fly through the air was,
it was,
it looked like it was fun.
It was fine.
Yeah.
And it was believable.
You did it.
Thank you.
You could bleed some challenges and it was a learning curve with the stunts and
the special effects and green screen all working together.
Um,
and it was a challenge,
but Miss Ava was right there in my corner and helping me and showing me
previous,
which is basically the animation of a what's going to be in the film.
So she helped a lot and it was still hard because you have to kind of,
you have to imagine the unimaginable,
which is really hard.
But it came together.
So there was one scene,
don't rat me out.
She did a really good job and you'll see it in the movie.
But there was one scene where I said,
okay,
storm
here in this place,
you're standing here in a field,
a tree is going to pop up,
fully grown from the crown.
And she's like,
okay.
And I said,
so can you imagine that?
But she's an actress,
so she's a magic.
She,
she goes through her feelings.
So she's never experienced a tree popping up from the ground believe.
So she was like,
ah,
so it's going to just pop up like,
like pop up from the ground or on top of the ground.
I said no from the ground storm from the ground up type approach to it.
Um,
but,
um,
but those are the kinds of fantastic spaces that she found herself in.
And when she was 13 year old years old,
she did it.
So when you watch the movie,
imagine this 13 year old actress,
brilliant girl doing all of these amazing things.
Um,
she's a real warrior of our movie.
True.
I love it.
Store
Megan's a beloved character
to and a brave and determined girl,
a physics wiz.
Uh,
you've mentioned that you really saw yourself in that character.
What was it about meg?
Yes.
Um,
well when I was reading a wrinkle in time in the sixth grade,
um,
I,
I didn't see myself as being meg because she wasn't written that way.
And I'm a very visual person.
So if I'm reading something and something is written a way,
then that's how it is and I could love it.
And I did.
Um,
but once I got the script and Miss Eva sent it over to me,
I felt like it just all clicked and it made sense and it made sense for a girl
at the center of the universe to be African American,
to represent African American girls.
And just girls in general.
Yes.
Just represent girls in general.
And then going into meg,
I feel like meg,
everybody can find a little piece of meg in,
in themselves.
And I feel like meg is very determined and strong willed and I feel like I'm the
same way.
So I feel like personally we kind of are on the same level and I felt like as
girls and as just teenagers growing up in this kind of dark world,
we're just trying to grow up and find ourselves and surround ourselves by good
people.
And sometimes we have challenges and mistakes and faults on top of that.
So that's what we're all going through the storm.
We love it.
I think it's important to know too that uh,
eva fought to get this.
Meg,
she fought to get storm.
Would you tell that story?
Oh,
where is channeling?
Well,
there were a lot of girls all over the world who auditioned to be meg.
And you're looking for that special girl who,
um,
who,
who encompasses everything that this beautiful character,
uh,
has,
has symbolized for so many decades since the book was published in 1963.
And so,
uh,
you looking for the one girl and so out of the hundreds of girls that we saw a
storm,
Reid was the one who was meant to be meg.
And I think it really speaks to um,
uh,
everyone has their place.
Everyone has somewhere or someplace that they're meant to be someone in the
world that you are meant to be connected with in your family.
Some something that you're supposed to be in your classroom or in your life if
you're an adult.
And um,
and you once,
once you align with that place,
it just,
it just clicks.
And that's what happens.
Storm was in the,
not just in the right place at the right time,
her whole life.
She was moving towards being in that audition room and being ready to be meg.
All of the little steps that brought her to be in the place,
in the time,
in this space to fulfill and be something important to someone else.
And that was me.
And so whether you're an actress and it's your time to be in a movie,
which is a rare thing,
or whether it's your opportunity to be someone important to someone in your
life,
uh,
you have to cultivate yourself each and every day so that when the opportunity
comes to really stand up and step up and be someone important to someone that
you're ready to do that.
And storm did that.
So when it was tired time and I met her,
she was ready to be someone important to me to be someone
who carries this whole movie.
So I really just,
just,
um,
I think her journey,
uh,
can speak to anyone in terms of prepare every day in your life to be a great
person so that when the moment of greatness arises,
you're ready for it.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
you play Doctor Kate Marie makes mother and a scientist and an equal partner,
tier wild scientist,
physicist,
husband.
What did that feel like?
And it rumor is that you got to hang out at NASA.
Is that true?
Uh,
yeah.
Well it was a real honor for me.
I think,
you know,
getting to work with ava who I admired for such a long time,
getting to play a scientist as you said,
you know,
in the book she's often described as Mrs. Murray and the idea that we have
doctor Kate that she's not just defined by her marriage,
that she,
you know,
is an equal partner to um,
Dr. Alex Murray played by Chris Pine.
And um,
for me it was really fascinating to kind of cling on to this idea that he's been
away for four years.
You know,
what this marriage and this family is based on is obviously love,
but also this intellectual meeting of minds that she's really found her partner
in life who is,
you know,
we sort of talked about them like this sort of power,
couple of science,
you know,
that they would do these ted talks that they were sort of like this,
this,
I don't know,
that,
that their connection was,
was intellectual and not just love and family.
And that's what really kept her going and kept her trying to figure out where he
was,
you know,
in that long time.
So yes,
we did get to go and visit JPL in Pasadena,
which was fascinating.
Getting to meet real,
have you beams.
I go,
yes,
I'm getting to meet real scientists,
people who are really planning missions to Mars.
It was,
it was so interesting.
And we also met this wonderful as doctor a Dr. Stephen Alexander who wrote this
book called the Jazz of physics.
Um,
and you know,
he sort of correlated the link between the work of John Coltrane,
the saxophonist and um,
science and physics.
And,
and I mean it was mind blowing to me and I can't pretend that I have retained
all of it.
I'll give you a pop quiz.
But it was great.
And the fact that ava sort of had him as the consultant on the movie to be able
to sort of introduce us to that,
that world of science
prior experience for you all.
And for us all,
you know,
Time magazine notes and it's a review of the movie that the book and the movie
is about what it means to be a source of light in a world in which darkness
seems only to proliferate.
Oprah,
you have a beautiful line in the movie about darkness being stronger than like,
can you talk to us a little bit about that because several of you have already
mentioned darkness in the world.
And this was such an inspiring,
what I think is incredible is that when Madeline lingual wrote it in 1962,
she was talking about the Cold War and all of the,
um,
experiences of that day and um,
civil rights movement and everything that was,
was,
uh,
on,
you know,
people were facing.
And what I know is that you're never going to run out of darkness as you're not
going to run out of light because this is the planet earth.
And we are the planet of Yin and Yang of darkness and light of opposites.
And so the darkness,
which Mrs which says is spreading so fast these days,
the only thing faster than light is the darkness.
And so you need warriors of the light to help banish the darkness.
If you think about it,
if we turn all the lights off in this room and you were only holding a small
candle,
that candle would light up the darkness and would help to banish the darkness.
It only takes a little bit of your light to banish the darkness.
It takes a lot of darkness to over come the light,
but just a little flicker from you.
And so wherever there is confusion,
wherever there's jealousy as mrs which talks about and is able to show everyone
in the movie what that darkness looks like,
where it shows up in your life,
just just a little bit of your light helps to dissipate and destroy that.
So I think it's about these times and all times are about you reaching for the
light inside yourself.
And that's the real work of your life is to figure out who you are and how do
you become more of who you are,
not what your friends are,
not even what your mother and your father and everybody wants you to be.
But this journey,
particularly at this stage in your development,
is about who am I and how do I become more of that and how do I bring more of my
light first to yourself?
Because you've got to give it to yourself first.
You can't give to yourself what you don't have,
so you fill yourself up.
And I used to be so afraid of people saying,
oh,
she's so full of herself.
She's so full of herself and now I work on,
you've heard that before.
Okay,
forget those people.
Those,
those,
those people are not your friends.
What you want to work on is filling yourself up with as much light,
as much kindness,
as much goodness,
as much preparation because that's what luck is.
Being prepared.
So when the moment of opportunity shows up,
a lot of people will look at storm and say,
oh,
she's so lucky.
She's lucky because she was prepared.
Luck is just preparation,
meeting that moment of opportunity.
If she wasn't prepared,
she wouldn't be here.
So your job is to fill yourself with as much light.
Light comes from all that is good.
All that is grace,
all that is kindness and then offer that to the world that will be your gift to
the world.
So that's why I love this movie.
Yes,
I saw
it says all
hope and thank you all for [inaudible]
being warriors for the light and for goodness.
And now I think we have,
since we are live streaming on youtube,
we have a few questions for all of you from our global audience.
So we're going to go to them,
hey e and explaining it then it was the Muslim [inaudible] and we see later
Milo.
[inaudible] e [inaudible].
Yes.
Well thank you.
Great crushes.
Quiet question from Spain of the soundtrack of the movie is beautiful.
Um,
one of the first,
the first artists that,
um,
I put on the soundtrack was storm reads,
favorite artists just because I wanted to make her happy,
but also because,
um,
because she's a great artist.
Her name is Kelani
but she's on that,
she's on the bees.
And then one of my favorite artists,
cause I want to make myself happy to Shaw day is
so incredible.
Uh,
see is on the album.
Chloe and Halle are on the album,
Demi Lavato and DJ Khaled or on the album.
Um,
so it's a really,
really great mix of voices and they kind of,
you put the music with the images and it just uplifts you as you watch the film.
Wonderful.
Beautiful.
We have a question next from France.
Oh,
bowls.
Jewel Brazil.
Oh,
it's Brazil,
not France.
It is you.
You're the
[inaudible].
Beautiful.
She's implant
Nathan [inaudible] essays.
These was contagious
bay shore.
Yeah.
I mean for me,
probably growing up confidence I was,
I was relatively confident.
I was an only child so I didn't have many people to play with and stuff like
that.
So for me,
actually acting gave me confidence.
I think being able to find something that I loved.
I loved dancing.
Initially when I was about four or five,
I went to dance class and I just loved,
I feeling free expressing myself with my buddy.
It sort of helped me get rid of my inhibitions and it was so much fun.
I think there's so much play to be had in,
in acting.
So I think it's,
um,
yeah,
finding what you love and,
and just just sticking with that.
And I obviously was lucky enough to make my hobby my job,
but um,
but yeah,
it gave me a lot of competence,
acting and dancing.
Beautiful.
Well,
we could talk for another hour,
but I'm afraid you all have to get on flights to London so you can open the
movie there tomorrow.
I want to thank all of our guests for being here.
Uh,
Disney's a wrinkle in time is in theaters tomorrow,
March 9th.
Go see it.
Large March tonight
before we let you go,
however we can
because it's so exciting.
We would like to invite all the girls from girls sync onto the stage.
Oh
yeah.